en este punto han muerto tres palestinos
el ejército israelí disparó contra ellos
y detuvo un cuarto aseguran que iban
armados el Primer Ministro Benjamín
netanyahu se alegró por estas muertes me
gustaría felicitar a los combatientes de
golán y que eliminaron a tres
terroristas en samaria como todos
podemos ver nuestras fuerzas están
operando las 24 horas del día contra
aquellos que buscan matarnos el
principio es simple cualquiera que
intente hacernos daño o nos hace daño
pagará el precio el suceso fue cerca de
naplusa en el norte de cisjordania una
zona en disputa donde Palestina quiere
construir su estado
los jóvenes muertos pertenecían a la
brigada de Mártires de alaxa una rama
armada del partido fata del presidente
de la autoridad Palestina mahamutaás las
familias quieren despedirse de sus hijos
Entonces si ellos tienen a nuestros
hijos los queremos No pedimos nada más
queremos que nuestros hijos estén aquí
que los podamos enterrar Y poder volver
a verlos
desde principios de año 80 palestinos
han sido asesinados en operativos
israelíes en 2022 fueron cerca de 150 en
el año más letal desde 2004
las incursiones de Israel son cada vez
más frecuentes en un endurecimiento del
gobierno más a la extrema derecha en 55
años un conflicto sin resolver desde que
en 1967 Israel invadiese cisjordania la
franja de gaza y el este de Jerusalén en
la guerra de medio oriente